It's...
[Interrupting] I think you should...
Go on, try again.
It's time for...
[Interrupting] It's time for you and me to go and....
We all know that it’s not always easy trying
to do two things at the same time,
but often we actually do it without even noticing.
Why is it sometimes easy and sometimes hard?
In this activity, you and your children will
investigate
why some types of multitasking are much harder
than others.
Have you ever tried to do two things at the
same time?
No!
Stand on one leg, then turn this round like
that.
Then you have to try and draw a 6 in the air.
Why is that so hard?
Rotating your foot in one direction and trying
to rotate your arm
in the opposite direction is hard
because you are using the same part of your
brain to guide both limbs.
We say that these two tasks “interfere”
with each other.
So I've got some other tasks here that we
can also try and do at the same time.
You’ll need six tasks all together.
We used turning your arm clockwise, turning
your foot anti-clockwise,
reading, listening to someone talk, counting,
and listening to someone else count,
but you and your children could try coming
up with your own.
You'll see that each one is identified as
being a 'body', 'words' or 'numbers' task.
Highlight these as you go through, to get
your child thinking
about whether the task's identity might have
an effect.
Pick one from the top.
Moving your arm.
And pick one from the side.
Reading! OK, what I'd like you to do is read
a page of your book,
whilst turning your hand round like that.
Aaah that's easy!
Go on then, show me, I bet it's not!
[Reading] Tilly and her friends...
Reading and moving your arm use different
parts of your brain,
so there is less interference which makes
the tasks easy to do at the same time.
Let's mark on here whether it's easy or difficult.
So you said it was
Easy!
So we put a big tick here...
Record your results in a table.
This is a good way to start observing the
results of your experiments,
and will also help you figure out whether
there is a pattern
to which type of activities are difficult
to do at the same time.
Listening to me speaking and reading at the
same time.
It's...
[Interrupting] I think you should...
Play around with the various combinations
and ask lots of questions as you go.
Is that hard or is that easy?
Hard!
You should find that tasks of the same type,
which are using the same areas of the brain,
will cause more confusion,
while tasks that use different areas of the
brain are easier to perform at the same time.
You move your hands all the time and you move
your feet all the time,
why is it so hard to do at the same time?
I couldn't move them the different ways!
Do you think one reason they were so difficult
is that they were so similar?
You can also overcome this interference with
practice.
You’ll probably find patting your head and
rubbing your stomach hard at first,
but with practice it becomes easier and easier
as your brain learns
to treat that particular combination as one
single activity, rather than two.
We've had loads of fun today.
To find out more and find out more about the
science of the experiments,
visit the Ri website [rigb.org/experimental],
and don't forget to like and subscribe!